two ways you can look at this opening
scene one it takes you right into the
action
- it's so dimly lit that you can't see
what the action is I'm sure that's
called perspective but honestly I insist
the bad guys pay for fluorescence so
that I can see what the hell is going on
Wow somebody saw Hunger Games as we're
about to see this movie just flat-out
demands I read the book before watching
amnesia yeah but normal people usually
bring up the exceptions during the rules
portion of the exposition what'd you
just say maze because this huge maze is
supposed to be a secret for some reason
you can't
no one needs especially not now could
you be any more fucking vague movie why
will you tell me what's out that's not
section man I will never understand this
logic in movies if something out they
were super dangerous why do you think
someone will be eager to seek it out
once you tell them about it they are
more likely to be curious and do
something stupid if you don't tell them
what it is welcome to the glade where
nothing is ever explained nice time I'm
gonna let you leave damn just tell me
that the maze has scary monsters in it
and this would've been a problem and why
doesn't this dude say that in response
he just stands there like those guys
were right to be angry with me about
something I had no knowledge about why
do these guys go through the trouble of
lighting torches - then throw them a
total of three feet since when did these
assholes become buddies nothing we've
seen so far in this movies first 11
minutes suggest that anyone will want to
hang out with this dude alone right now
but Love Actually over here makes fast
friends with it somehow I guess because
of their love of model trains probably
model trains out of the first day
greenie
like greenie would know put some hair on
his chest jars of amber liquid are
rarely fit for human consumption
they run the maze not me memorizing
they're trying to find a way out
is the names changing some revelations
about the maze are made later but why
doesn't Thomas ask the question if the
maze changes every night then how do you
map it or memorize it there are no girls
in the glade for some reason probably to
keep these maze running buoys focused on
maze running instead of chasing and it's
never explained or connected to the goal
the bad guys of course will probably
find out later they're on some big TV
show or something and this is like
Truman Show Running Man or something
that we've got the bill is apparently to
be a successful young adult franchise
you need to separate everyone into four
groups once you find out which one's the
bravest you can ignore all the others
isn't that right hufflepuff chosen by
who
every time this dude asks a question of
visual answer happens immediately stop
calling you that would be called shank
that is not funny I also have no idea
what that means but it sounds better
than greeny rapidly edited blurry barely
registers as helpful flashback cliche is
you're not like the others you're
curious okay so you're telling me that
the majority of people who get sent to
this place surrounded on all sides by a
wall and a big fucking maze they're just
like huh I want to know even less about
my mysterious situation when can I do
the laundry guys I bet someone's right
behind him this camera movement does not
lie also we find out later that this guy
got stung while in the maze so why is he
running out of the maze after getting
stung straight to this location where
Thomas is right now hey I wonder if
they're gonna fall down some sort of
slope that comes out of nowhere during
this woodsy chase scene yep hold him
down that guy's dead right he got hit in
the face with a shovel then stongest
middle of the day don't ever change
movie I like you just the way you are
confusing and terrible it's called the
changing it's what happens is someone
gets done and that's all I have to say
about that you think he might make it
yeah damn dude didn't tell you that no
one survives a night in the maze no
one's ever survived the night do we even
need the scene second rapidly edited
blurry barely registers as helpful
flashback provides slightly more
information than the first flashback
cliche will have to do damn if this guy
wasn't constantly waking up from his
flashbacks he to figure out why he's
here and probably where to go in the
maze by now how he went to retrace Ben's
footsteps before sundown
how do you retrace someone steps from a
previous day when the maze changes every
night
someone had to spend a whole month in
the glade alone that was Alby
how did Alby get set up here by himself
a CMAs and either not walk into it or
walk into it and figure out everything
you needed to know in order to make sure
he didn't die
be back by now what happens if they
don't make it you've had this question
answered twice now dude
then Thomas sees people before people
are visible also Thomas is the only
person to see people despite everyone
looking in the same direction he is why
would you do this look like stump
oh yeah it's pretty obvious to see that
when you disregard the absence of light
what happened to his head I do what I
had to do this isn't the pronoun game
but it's a distant cousin and this movie
has worn my patience thin by playing it
I don't even care what's going on
anymore that's how pissed I am about
this everyone is coy about everything
bolt is already Gigi you do isn't this
passageway the exact same one we saw
earlier in the movie let's do a
side-by-side comparison shall we the one
on the left is from earlier in the movie
the one on the right is the most recent
one looks like the exact same passage to
me same markings same rocks on the
ground same IV strands same thing
passageway that never changes according
to what we've seen so camp out next to
the door you don't get it we're already
dead because no one blah-blahs one night
in the BLA thank god the unspoken evil
in this maze ignores these guys long
enough for them to rig up this Albie
saving device and for the Sun to go down
also couldn't the filmmakers have found
another way to save Albie because this
seems kind of tone-deaf this hiding in
the vines thing works I guess because
the Earth's are ripoff is blind and you
can continue like you did just a minute
ago discount she lobe character with no
hearing or spatial reasoning doesn't
even think about looking up or hearing
this creature drools on Thomas to give
him the heads up
and also rips off the Alien franchise in
the process I take a sin on four balls
eNOS if I wasn't such a big alien fan
well he's a literal Maze Runner now am i
right this is kind of an unspoken rule
credits in here thankfully for this
asshole Wrigley Field was nearby this
unexplained bug thing has storm trooper
aim but I actually predicted that so
it's sinful but not surprising it's
blurry and jump-cut so let me spell it
out for you cuz he just fell several
stories onto Rock and survived it just
fine movie thinks that we'll be tied up
in suspense as to whether Tonto survived
this told each other while coming back
because no one blah-blahs in the river
you can just see it he chose it well the
rapidly closing Mays wall helped I mean
you make it sound like a Jaden Smith
ghost did this grievers ass and it was
really just good timing and now our
greenie here has taken it upon himself
to go into the maze which is a clear
violation of our rules here always only
means community court proceedings
saved alby's life did he look dude I
hate this as much as you do but yes he
did save alby's life Jesus for three
years we have coexisted with these
things and now you've killed one of them
wait you clearly stated multiple times
that these things have killed your
people how is that a peaceful
coexistence that sounds like predatory
dominance to me the Society of maize
Neverland boys is actually considering
punishing Thomas for doing something
good
well nothing bad is gonna happen to her
in this prison colony of nature boys
nope she'll be fine and that's exactly
how the smurfs got Smurfette the note
said she's the last one ever but the
boys automatically assume one of a few
interpretations of that note they
believe it means no more people will
ever be set up in the box grammatically
it's entirely possible that all women on
the planet are dead except for this new
girl or that the maze masters are
granting the Klan one fertile female for
procreation but only the one such a
short note it's kind of dumb to make any
assumptions really somebody's gonna have
some mosses right here you would think
but wouldn't some of them be excited
that a greenie killed one of those
things that kind of negates the Alby got
stung part right
you mean the woods in half an hour in
that one specific spot we prearranged
long before this conversation but are
definitely not discussing right now why
did they have to meet discreetly in the
woods if they were just gonna run out in
the open to go into the maze and if no
one was gonna even notice them leaving
[Music]
come on you don't see the blinking red
light emanating from the dark chasm
where the griever was killed first he
breaks our rules and then he tries to
convince us to abandon him totally his
characters Dances with Wolves name would
be disagrees with everyone about
everything in the face of logic and
facts with a fist starting from tomorrow
you're a runner Wow
I understand why this guy is upset that
Thomas isn't getting a real punishment
but damn why does it matter if they make
him a runner or not the other assholes
quit so there's plenty of people to farm
and cut down trees and no hay where are
we going
yes it's not so much a surprise for you
but maybe the audience there's really no
reason not to tell you it's the maze all
of it doesn't it change constantly how
would any kind of model be worthwhile or
accurate what's going on also the movie
suggests that the means changing is a
lot but it's really a lie to the
audience because the maze runners could
have simply told the colony we haven't
found the exit yet because this thing is
impossibly huge a potentially really
cool aspect of this maze is it reduced
into an unsatisfying Santa Claus isn't
real moment
what's so special about seven who said
there was anything special about section
seven it just happened to be the section
that was open last night just like any
other random section but the movie is
telling us the section means something
more than that and that Thomas has the
most amazing intuition since Sherlock
Holmes think it must be where it comes
from it's more you're now gonna take a
closer look but you just said the maze
has a pattern where it opens a different
section every day and it's the same
pattern no matter what through 8c the
way it works is every night when the
maze changes it opens up a new section
should I take you at least a week before
you can explore section seven again it's
the girl what if she wait did you say
and during the entire run back those
guys didn't tell Thomas or me know what
was going on did she wake up and gather
a bunch of rocks before she climbed up
here or does this tower just have lots
of rocks up on top of it why can't I
remember anything this is all normal
your name that'll come back to you in a
couple of days it's the one thing that's
reason you just said you didn't remember
anything you sure you don't number
anything else this is a question only
what needs to stop having characters ask
people with memory loss because it's
stupid as hell and because it's only in
movies to service some kind of oh yeah I
know that I think harder I do actually
remember something else bull revelation
the others don't remember anything no
well they don't really say much about
anything they know they barely wanted to
tell me this maze was dangerous earlier
they don't even know what this stuff is
we don't know who sent it why I came up
here with you and guys sent up an
antidote but don't give any instructions
that that's what it is also movie rips
off the mysterious medicine for
mysterious people sent in to help the
gamers thing from Hunger Games sundown
greenie Tom ago oh yeah they're still
intending to punish him even though
they're all listening to him like a
leader now that still makes no sense
which is probably I forgot it was even
supposed to happen hey what is your
problem with me everything started going
wrong the minute you showed up first Ben
then Alby you know I do believe people
think stuff like this in real life but
we're going to send real life here how
the fuck do you blame Ben and I'll be
getting stung in the maze on anyone
especially the dude who was forced to be
a horticulturist when he got here that's
changed what sevens not supposed to be
open for another week exactly but isn't
that why you came here in the first
place to examine what was so special
about section 7 I am confused what the
hell is this place become blades because
in this movie we have a catchy nickname
for everything you greenie shank I think
it's showing us the way showing you the
way to what what are you even talking
about
anyway you ever see this place before Oh
even though the doors to this place were
wide open
this is why the communication in this
movie is awful does it mean that he's
never seen this place before because
it's some brand-new section he's never
noticed or because the doors were closed
and they could never actually open them
we never find out why does this thing
have three walls of security is this a
setup where you can actually get past
the first wall and the second wall says
nope you on top of that yet another gate
is here for no reason this is like the
opening of the TV show Get Smart
honestly if your backpack is this tiny
you have defeated the purpose of wearing
a backpack in the first place not to
mention the backpack harness not now nor
ever in the film does anyone express
surprise that the grievers turned out to
be machines not nobody not know how
inception jump-scare also an alarm
sounds yet the three walls of security
don't immediately come down in fact they
wait a long damn time before they even
start to come down the problem with the
scene is we don't even know what awaits
thomas when he's running down this one
corridor we don't know if he'll be
trapped or what but van will be glad he
made it to mean his side which doesn't
look any better than the side he was on
then this happens they escape the blades
but looking in the background there are
clearly corridors that would've trapped
them under any circumstance was that the
roof of this thing is clearly touching
Thomas's back in the shop but in the
next shot an easy escape is to be had
with time to spare
the truth is Thomas doesn't know what
he's done as usual book the movie has a
moving maze griever monsters and
all-seeing gamemaster's do we really
need cliche antagonist number 13 as well
Jesus maybe you should start doing
things a little different maybe you
should be in charge
that's what screenwriters get Teresa to
interrupt this argument because it was
clearly going nowhere also this girl
still isn't getting hit with a thousand
cheesy pickup lines per minute Albee
only speaks in big sentences so that
Newt has to keep asking him questions
until he finally gets to the goddamn
point already what was their favorite
Thomas oh this movie is so annoying al
me now adds the pronoun game did a list
of vagaries and then some everyday
normal shouting distracts everyone so he
can't fill in the blanks bird signal
something off will come in cliche okay
even if you could hide in this cornfield
from grievers that saw you two seconds
ago which you could not you're gonna
keep burning that flight too
you deserve to be killed Reaper waits
entirely too long to attack when they've
been doing nothing but offing fools this
entire scene jar of something ex machina
this wooden door keeps this thing out a
bunch of teenage boys are way too
confident that they are safe inside this
structure built by a bunch of teenage
boys I thought this thing found a way in
a group caved in now it's just randomly
punching walls hoping to grab victims
thankfully for the story's hard-on for
unexplained mysteries Alby gets taken by
a griever before he can reveal what he
learned by
remembering everything Ruby keeps
repeating things that I say aloud all
the grievers gone were they released for
only three minutes and my Jesus this
movie is more interested in surprising
you than any of the details of its
actual story well it's a good thing we
could sent to antidote miles when Alby
got stung or else this might seem like a
rash decision
third rapidly edited blurry barely
registers as helpful flashback provides
slightly more information than the first
yeah
God he's taking control he said we had a
choice need to join him get banished to
sundown with you great but I met with
the grievers that were killing everyone
also how does Gally have the manpower to
do this haven't we seen more support for
Thomas than Gally and most everyone is
dead now right this Gally ascends to the
throne that seems unlikely as hell but
honestly I'm Way more concerned about
the suddenly disappearing grievers guys
I'm one of them I was on the other side
of it so are you damn you just threw
that chick under the bus dude she she
always did this - no it can't be true it
is I saw um no you didn't unless we
didn't see everything you saw all you
saw was you with a computer screen movie
needs to stop trying to surprise me and
just come up with a fucking story
already you went into the maze and you
found a way out whoa whoa whoa he found
a dark hole that had griever sounds in
it but it's all he found I am serious
about this
I'm breeding three small strands in the
back of my hair together for this Chuck
who was just told to stay at the back
you take this Chuck stay behind this is
directly behind Thomas the lead
screaming runner makes you wonder how
they would have won if we could have
built this room with convenient let
gravity decide this chasms to push
grievers down into grievers which were
built up as these impossible to beat
creatures have suddenly become such
bitches that people can discuss security
codes while fending them off griever
comes literally out of nowhere to fall
on the one guy who's yelling the
combination right now now that these
assholes are out and walking down a
hallway roughly 17 minutes before this
movie is over I realize how much of a
sucker I am for watching what is clearly
at divergent levels of movie that is
merely a setup for another movie
bullshit
also let me guess they're going to meet
a moderately famous actor who tells them
some important but mysterious
information that Cliff Hanks right
seriously movie keeps repeating things I
say out loud oh look how right I was
about this movie desperate to be
surprising that is actually altogether
entirely too predictable here's a
moderately famous actress about to
explain everything and nothing
if you're watching this that means
you've successfully completed the maze
trials it also means you need to press
this particular button mana council that
was not immediately obvious
suddenly there was a reason to hope for
a cure but finding it would not be easy
the young would have to be tested even
sacrificed inside harsh environments
movie back loads the exposition it's
been trying to hide from you all movie
because honestly I have no fucking clue
it's basically a bait and switch to get
you to watch the second movie
oh it's one of those delayed reaction
guns that shoots bullets where you only
know you've been shot 10 seconds later
and the blood flows intent and with that
realization and chuck is dead because
you've totally cared about truck right I
mean he brought food to Thomas in the
hole and did virtually nothing else this
entire film you built all this on a
hunch that watching diseased immune kids
and this thing might tell you something
about why they're immune sure they're
probably lying but I'm beginning to
think any explanation for this is
probably bull you mean before I even
understand anything that just happened
it's time now to begin phase two
we're supremely confident than all the
confusion this movie caused will bring
people not familiar with the books back
for more
[Music]
what is this place let me show you I can
show you the world shining shimmering
splendid
[Music]
[Applause]
now where you sit in the cafeteria is
crucial because you got everybody there
you got your freshman ROTC guys preps JV
jocks Asian nerds who Asians
I remember my name I'm Thomas his name
is Robert Paulson
so what you gotta do is you gotta be
needle down in a stabbing motion I gotta
I gotta stab her three times
[Music]
normally I'd be here to warn you about
an app but this time I'm here to warn
you about a book actually I'm not even
really warning you very well since I
didn't start talking until after the
image was already on screen and now I'm
already out of time